welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for our presentation titled
effective rna extraction for covid19
testing it's my pleasure to introduce
you to gabrielle fernandez
general manager of the genomics and
diagnostic solutions at satova and chris
norway r d leader genomics and cellular
research at
sativa for complete biography of our
speaker please visit the tab at the top
of your screen if any questions arise
during this presentation we encourage
you to submit them in the q a box our
speaker will address your questions
following the end of the presentation
please join me now in welcoming both of
our presenters gabrielle and chris i
will now turn the presentation over to
them welcome gentlemen
hello everyone
thanks for the introduction as uh
it was said i'm gabriel fernandez i'm
the general manager of the genomics and
diagnostic solution business part of
sativa
and together with chris nori our head of
rna i'm going to talk about the
effective rene extraction for copy 19
test development
as you can see we have a very packed
agenda so i'm going to go straight to
the introduction which is
why this is important for us
and why we're doing it
so
we took this snapshot
just a few days ago and as for sure you
know
things are even worse in terms of a
number of people infected and number of
deaths around the world
normally
a scietiva will remain behind the
curtains
helping key developers around the world
with our
macbeths
and
services and components
but in this case we really thought we
need to do
something more
on my personal case i
in it was in march
when i was uh
talking with my mom who is a pharmacist
based in spain
which is one of the areas in europe that
has been mostly affected by this
pandemic
and she was going
every day to the pharmacy
and she was sent me sending pictures to
me with her gloves with her mask trying
to help as many people as she could
and really that pushed me and and
actually everyone in the team had the
same other reasons to do something more
than what we normally do
and that's why uh you know
we developed the kid that chris uh will
share in a few minutes and that's why we
continue to work for additional
solutions to help with the bottlenecks
of this pandemic
we know that till we have a vaccine
diagnostic is the best we got
and it's important for us to contribute
as much as we can
for this uh for this reason
so just to get the the the fundamentals
right
and i'm sure that a lot of you are
familiar with this but uh first
juno's covenanting
is not the is just the disease is not
the virus the virus is called such cop2
which uh relates to the virus that
was uh happening around 2003 which was
sarskoff
which is also called uh you know
coronavirus so that's why this one we
call it corona novel coronavirus or well
sometimes new coronavirus or sometimes
chronologists on its own
it is a
placenta rna virus uh which
bean plastics means that it kind of
copied itself directly which expands
faster
and as you can see in the images you
know have the r is have a capsule
structure
which means that the rna is inside and
you have these spike proteins that are
in the in the image are on red and
orange
which are the the proteins that the
the virus used to attack and infect the
cells
so if we go
then closer to what are the current uh
technologies to for copied 19 detection
just to provide a better framework
i really like this schematic because
it's really simple and uh it's uh it's
easy to to follow yeah so
as you can see there are really two type
of detection you can either try to
detect
the immune
response uh to the virus or you can try
to detect the virus itself
so if you try to uh detect the immune
response you're trying to look for and
the antibodies that your body has
generated
and that is typically done in blood only
and
it can be detected through a lateral
flow or chemoluminescence
now if you're
trying to identify the people that are
infected you are looking to detect the
virus
and you can do two ways
you can either try to detect those spike
proteins that were in the outside
and for that
you will do a lateral flow type of test
or
you can try to find the rna that truly
identifies that rna of the that is
inside of the virus and for that you
will have an rt pcr test
both tests has
some pros and cons
so the pros of the rtpcr test is that
first is
it can be developed really really
quickly so as soon as you can
sequence the virus which was done very
very quickly
then
you can have a artificial test
the second key advantage is because you
are reading through the rna of the virus
you can really
have a very good er
like reliability of the test
the cons
it has to do with the with two things
one is the speed
uh
in terms of
the test takes you tends to take longer
although different teams around the
world work to shorten that time of uh of
the test itself
and the second is and i'm sure you have
seen on the news since since march is
the different bottlenecks in different
parts of the of the process
in terms of raw materials equipment and
things like that
when you look to a lateral flow
uh i mean it has some very good
advantages so the test is very fast so
in minutes you know if that you have the
virus or not and they are typically
cheaper
the negative side it comes from the fact
that
um
because
two
proteins are very very complex which
means that it takes much longer to
develop
an appropriate lateral flow test
and also
it is difficult to
get it to a level of
reliability that people can get
comfortable with
so i will say that personally if i want
to be sure if i have the copied or not i
will go right now for an rt pcr test
so let's get closer on the process for
what is the rtp here
so
we can simplify the the process into
just three steps
one is the sample collection
you have the viral rna purification
and finally you have the rt pcr
amplification there as you can see there
in the image you have a number of ways
to collect the sample
the
golden standard at the moment is the
upper respiratory tract
now if we go to the
other areas which are probably more
important for us
if you go to eval rna purification the
first step
is you need to inactivate the virus
because you don't want anyone to get
infected with the sample if it's
infected
so for that
there's sometimes the uh the transfer
media like the one that the chris nary
would mention will mention later from
prime store for example it has a buffer
to to the buffer inactivate the virus
but also the kits that are provided for
example with our magnetic beads also
provide the lysis buffer that will
inactivate the virus
then once once the virus is inactivated
the next step is to extract the rna
you can have like the typical spin
column which is very very traditional
and you can have with magnetic bits
the advantage of the macbeth bits is
that it allows you to have a much bigger
automation which when you are handling a
lot of samples
that means that you have a much higher
throughput yeah so
i think that's a critical aspect and
then if we talk on automation
of course you know you can still
automate the spin columns but to a
certain limit so that's mostly for the
magnetic bits
and i would highlight that there are two
types of automation platforms
you have the open platforms
and you have the closed platforms
the closed platforms
are like an iphone
it has a very nice ecosystem everything
connects very well with each other and
everything works very well
in the situation of a pandemic
the problem with a closed system is that
do you want to rely on what on one
single supplier for everything
uh especially when there's a scarcity on
some of the elements and so so i think
that's something to take in conversation
around open platforms versus closed
platforms
finally you have the rt pcr
amplification you can have one step or
you have two steps
and the there's more right now i think
it's more typical the one step versus
the two steps just because of the
simplicity you have both the rt enzyme
and the attack polymerase together
and
it gets activated through through heat
and it's relatively simple
there are number of uh pcr platforms
available
and
we you know at the other day
the rtpcr results is very well
the result of how good destruction uh
did go yeah so
that's why
today we're talking mostly about the
effective rn extraction so
i will now pass it to to chris who will
talk about the product we have developed
thanks gabrielle
and hello everybody it's a pleasure to
be joining you on this webinar today
as gabrielle mentioned
i'm going to talk a little bit more
about the specific details around the
kit that we've developed
and the importance from a testing point
of view
as he mentioned it's test touching every
one of us i think this situation myself
my wife works as an icu nurse and so
testing and understanding this
status of patients is critical to know
what kind of treatments to to look for
and obviously with track and trace being
an important component of
dealing with the pandemic situation the
ability to do the testing as gabriel
mentioned is critical
just to talk a little bit more about the
methods that we use as gabrielle
mentioned we
extract the rna sample
and we're using a synthetic sars ii rna
as a mimic for our assay development as
well as some synthetic viral particles
so
it contains the sarskoff ii
rna structure but it's packaged into a
synthetic symbis-like virus particle
we thought prepare mixed the rt qpcr
master mix with primers and probes
and the genes that we're using for our
testing are the engine
probes uh the n1 n2 and n3 probes that
people may be familiar with
we dispense the master mix i'll equate
to a quarter sample of the
test material into a plate or a tube
and run the cube
pcr on a system
with the different primers and different
probes
essentially what happens is as you go
through the different cycles
the probe is converted into a
fluorescent signal
and that signal increases
more quickly the more of the rna is
present
and we're looking therefore for the
cycle number that we start to see the
emergence of the fluorescent signal
and usually anything under 40 cycles is
considered as a positive test
that test can then be reported to the
clinician
or we're using that data to demonstrate
the efficacy of our kit as you'll see
later
in terms of the pcr reaction itself
as mentioned we extract the rna
we allocate it and the way the pcr
reaction works
is basically to go through a number of
heating steps in different cycles which
allows for the annealing of the probes
the extension of the
dna strand and then the dissociation to
create free strand reanneal the probes
and start that process all over again
and in every cycle you get a doubling of
the amount of target that's present
and therefore signal and hopefully over
a short period you end up with many
thousands millions of copies
of the template signal and that will
give you your fluorescent outcome
so let's talk a little bit more
specifically about the kit that we've
developed
and
and some of the data that comes along
with the with that
the kit itself is based on our magnetic
bead technology
we have some silica coated magnetic
beads
and that allows for good automation of
the samples and the systems
it allows for high throughput nucleic
acid isolation with this kit we can do
both dna and rna the data i'm going to
present today is primarily focused at
the ksaskov2 rna system
and what we found is that we are able to
generate good quality rna that is
compatible then with downstream
operations like next-gen sequencing
or cause
pcr determination
looking at some specific features of the
kit
it's a solid phase extraction based on
the magnetic beads and we've been able
to get good sensitivity of the assay
down to about one copy per microliter of
rna present
we can use both manual and automated
methods and that allows for very high
throughput and simple uh sample
processing
we've had a range of sample volumes that
we've tested uh up to 400 microliters of
sample if necessary
particularly for highly sensitivity
applications
it's a quick protocol so it allows us to
get through many samples and using
multi-world plates
many samples in a very short space of
time
we believe it's flexible as well having
used a number of different
biological samples and different
transport media and i'll touch on some
of those as we look at the data
and as mentioned it's compatible then
with downstream applications as well
so just to spend a little bit more time
uh
with the protocol itself
uh it's a very simple protocol and
primarily the num the way that we've
tested this is in a manual version and
much of the data that i'm going to
present is based on a manual assay but
we've also been able to automate the
process using the kingfisher system and
i'll show some of the data that we've
generated to demonstrate that automation
capability
essentially the protocols are the same
there are some
modifications and optimizations that
we've done
to ensure that the automation system
works as as well as the manual system
but essentially you start with your
input sample
and to that add the lysis buffer protein
sk and the beads and incubate for three
minutes or longer depending on the
nature of the sample potentially
after that incubation we pulled the
magnetic beads to the side of the tube
and removed the liquid
and the rna and dna that is bound to the
beet is therefore captured in the tube
we then do a couple of wash steps the
first one
is with
ethanol
and then
secondly with a wash buffer too
and again
you add the liquids
mix
pull the beets back to the side of the
tube and aspirate the liquid away and
the rna dna remains bound to the beads
we do a quick air dry
of those speeds
and then add the elusion buffer
and at this point the dna on rna is
released from the bead
so when you pull the beads to the side
of the tube you're able to aspirate out
your sample which contains the rna or
dna of interest
so now let's take a look at some of the
data that we've generated uh with the
kit uh that hopefully demonstrates that
we believe it's appropriate for testing
or use with testing of the this ascorb
to rna virus
in our first experiment um what we
wanted to do was take a look at the
performance of the kit from an
extraction perspective
and just see how that compared with some
published data from cdc um they have
data published on their website using a
particular kit um and that gives a
number of
uh ct cycles or
the number of cycles it takes to
generate the the signal as mentioned
before
for the the car sales 2 virus
in this instance we're using synthetic
rna
we're adding it to the prime store
transport media
and then we go through the protocol as
mentioned before
we're using the three n primers n1n2n3
as i mentioned and we also use an rna's
p gene as a control
that data is not shown on this graph
the graph just shows the outcome for the
three primer sets
uh both at 100 copies per microliter 10
copies per microliter or one copy per
microliter of the synthetic rna
and in the table below it just
summarizes that the
ct cycles that we observed
and as you can see they're very
comparable
with the cdc data that's been published
and therefore it gave us good indication
that the ex extraction process that
we're using with the kit
is rendering rna of sufficient quality
to go into the downstream rtpcr assay
in our second experiment we wanted to
extend that comparison to a more
empirical test
so in this instance we've done the same
testing
but this time we've done it side by side
with the kia mini elute virus spin kit
the one that was mentioned in the cdc
previously for the data that they
generated
just to see that in in a direct test
uh side by side that our our extraction
kit was still performing uh in a way
that was equivalent to the cdc
recommended kits
and as you can see from the graphs
the ct values again showing for 10
100 or one copy per microliter
using each of the three primer sets
between the two kits is very very
comparable
and we're getting a good control
reproducibility in the rna's p gene as
well
so again this confirmed for us that the
extraction process and the extraction
formulation that we've developed
is providing the right kind of rna
outcome to be able to do detection at a
sensitive level for the ksarskov 2 rna
i mentioned the importance of automation
particularly when it comes to processing
high throughput samples
so this next experiment was looking at a
comparison between the manual method and
the automated method
this is using the serra extractor kit
again with the prime store transport
media and the three primer sets and
rnasp as our control
and again what we can see is at the
different concentrations of synthetic
rna added 10 100 and one copy per
microliter we're getting very comparable
results between the manual method and
the automated method
and this means that we can use
automation to really speed up
the number of samples that we can do in
a testing type situation and be
confident that we're able to detect the
virus at the same level of sensitivity
as the manual method
in the next slide
we know that there are other pro
transport media that people are most
commonly using at the prime store meter
is a media that is an inactivating major
as gabrielle mentioned previously
but there are also a number of transport
media that are non-inactivating media
and one of the most common ones is a
media called the current utm
in these types of media the virus is not
inactivated it's simply stabilized
and so potentially has a different kind
of environment when it goes into the
extraction process and then onward
instead into rcpcr
so we wanted to test the effectiveness
of the extraction kit with these
non-inactivating transport media
so the data here you can see
is again using the synthetic rna
in the kit uh together with a manual
method and an automated method using
this time the copa transport media
again we're able to detect virus but
this time only down to about 10 copies
per microliter
robustly
we still see good performance of the
rna's p primer set throughout the
dilution set
but this did raise some questions as to
what was happening in the
non-inactivating transport medias and
one of our concerns was that because
we're only using synthetic rna
it was actually that the rna was being
degraded
as it was placed into that transport
media
and that therefore we weren't able to
detect the sensitivity levels that we
had been able to do so previously in the
prime stool media
so in order to investigate that further
we took a look at a different kind of
sample
in this instance as i mentioned we're
using recombinant viral particles
so here we've got the sarskoff ii rna
but it's now packaged into a synthetic
recombinant virus based on the symbis
virus
again using the non-inactivating
transport medias and again comparing the
manual with the automation method
and in this instance we're able to get
down to five viral copies per microliter
and this time the data is very
consistent and it's very consistent
between both the manual and the
automated method
and this really convinced us that
it's likely that with the
non-inactivating media we are suffering
from degradation of the synthetic rna
when you protect that rna in a in a
synthetic viral species then again
you're able to recreate the same kind of
sensitivity as we're able to see in the
non-inactivating media
so
what i'd like to do just to finish is
summarize some of the key points in
terms of the performance of the kit that
we have
our virus kit is designed to extract
nucleic acids from both rna and dna
viruses and other
pathogen species
although we focused primarily on the
sarskoff two
data in this presentation we have also
generated data with an influenza virus
so it's different rna virus but also
with some bio
dna pathogens also
adenovirus and also with a bacterial
species
i've demonstrated and shown that we can
use a variety of universal transport
medias both inactivating and
non-inactivating
and we've also got data that
demonstrates that we can
recover the rna from a variety of
biological species
in our experiments we're primarily using
rna that's
spiked into those transport medias but
we know through customer
interactions that people are using swap
based samples in those in those medias
saliva samples and we've also tested
blood in some of the the data that we've
created elsewhere
the yields that we get and the quality
that we get are very reproducible and
we've been able to demonstrate that
we're continually able to detect at
sensitivity levels down to one copy per
microliter
using the rt-pcr assay
so we have a good
quality of rna produced from the
extraction method
there's good flexibility in terms of the
sample that can be used both in terms of
volume but also how it can be handled
both in manual and automated fashion and
that gives great flexibility for users
and in terms of how they're doing their
testing at be it manual or needing
higher throughput using automation
and the process can take a very short
space of time can be completed in about
30 minutes and when you're multiplexing
that in in 96 or greater density plates
allows for a very high throughput
capability
one of the things that i haven't been
able to show here but we've been working
on more recently
is to expand that menu of the different
types of pathogen species that we're
able to detect
and also to look at the flexibility of
the method on automation platforms
we've been able to look at things like
the heating step the mixing steps and
the incubation steps and there is
flexibility there that we can introduce
into how the protocol runs
therefore giving even greater
flexibility for different sample types
different testing environments etc
and with that i'd like to hand back to
gabrielle to finish the presentation
thank you chris um so
as i was mentioning at the beginning uh
now we have many other uh
technologies
that we use to support copy 19.
so let me share it with that with you
so you've looked to a covenant in
so we can help with the sample
preparation we can help with detection
with the rtq pcr
we can mention help with sequencing
which is another way to detect the virus
and then we we help along the whole
process with our customized solutions so
let me talk to you briefly about each of
them
so on the customized solutions
there's some sessions in particular on
livestable
this is a technology that we have
to
stabilize
companies reagents
so they are able to be stored
at room temperature when normally they
will shoot they will they will store at
very negative temperatures we have a big
project for example with a company in
the uk called gene drive which is very
public and very successful
and we have but we have many others on
the way
we have a also services of uh contract
manufacturing and formulation beyond uh
the livestable
then if we go down to the different
steps so in sample preparation you know
we talked about the virus
pathogen kit but on top of that we have
a full range of magnetic bits for
example the csl bits are used um
actually for the structural virus and
paddling kit so if
we have
companies that want to build their own
kits or want to build their own
workflows using their own buffers uh
with the with those bits and same way
with the ceramic bits so we have
carboxyl oligo dt that that are
widely uh documented to be used for uh
extraction of rna and actually we know
they're actually used for coping 19 as
well
on top of that we have a poly a which is
a reagent that helps enhance the
sensitivity of the assays we have a lot
of stock of that one and then we have a
our spin rna spin columns and the plate
format
that actually does the rna instruction
as well
so that's on sample preparation
for detection we have uh
some probes there are nucleotides like
polymerase and side eyes and then on on
sequencing
we have basically it's mostly about our
ceramic beads
which are used all across the process
so
now talking on sequencing on an ngs
workflow
and just aside of what is a covet 19
we have built a a number of products
around the structure kits that were
on the ngs workflow
so
on top of the virus and pathogen kit we
have our we have launched earlier this
year the selfie dna kit and the genomic
dna kit
which is a full kit to extract dna and a
full kit to extract a self-rif for
liquid boxes
we also
have a
product for rna insulation will be
similar to the to the other page and for
ffp installation amplification and then
on the library preparation of course we
have uh you know our full reagent uh
ceramic select
and also exoprostar um to to help the
pcr clean up
so that's kind of a really quick
overview of our products i would like to
highlight that our products overall have
been used for um
to enable at least a 50 million pcr
tests around the world so so i think
it's it's a very good contribution for
for our side and really looking forward
for your questions now or
or later
thank you very much
and thank you gabrielle and chris for
that outstanding presentation we will
now move into the live q a portion of
the presentation and as a reminder
please submit your questions via the q a
box
so let's take a look we already have
an incredible number of questions coming
in for you gentlemen
our first question is
most patients tested for covid19 must
have developed symptoms meaning that the
viral load must have been high to cause
these symptoms
can this kit also give good sensitivity
for patients with less symptoms or lower
viral loads
yeah sure let me take that one um
yeah absolutely um with the testing that
we've been doing as mentioned in the
data we've been getting sensitivities
around one copy per microliter using the
synthetic rna and down to a couple of
copies per microliter for the viral
particles
with some of the testers that have tried
the kit um with real samples in the
field when they've got a patient that's
got a clear viral load for the for the
virus they're getting ct values of
around 20 or even lower
1820
levels
as indicated we can still get that one
copy per microliter at ct values of
around
35 to 40
indicating that there's a huge degree of
sensitivity in the assay
compared to those patients that have
have the the really visible symptoms as
it were and high viral load so yes we
believe that it does give good
sensitivity for
the lowest the less symptoms or early
stage of the virus yeah
wonderful thank you
and can
one use this kit for extracting nucleic
acids for testing other viruses for
example seasonal flu or even some
blood-borne viruses
yeah absolutely so um i think with one
of the first application notes that we
published on the website um we did some
uh data with both the sarskov ii virus
but also with influenza and also with a
a dna species as well so
whilst we've focused our attention um i
think quite rightly at this time on on
testing and if efficacy of the
extraction method for the
sales cough 2 virus
it is certainly applicable to other
rna and dna pathogen types
and certainly we have some
data with the the influenza virus as
well yes
thank you so much
our next question is is this kit
certified for ivd use
well i i can take that one uh so
it is not certified for iv use and it's
not our intention to certify for every
use
this is only an arrow kit
so and we want to allow the companies or
labs that are signing or or testing with
an rtq pcr the chemistry to validate the
results themselves and
because we think that the ibd status is
more important on the detection part on
the extraction kit so that's why uh we
have done it this way also i have to
mention that you know because that's
kind of our view of it of things we're
very happy also to uh to kind of make
custom versions of this obviously to
facilitate this process for any company
who is interested to to to kind of apply
for that for that market yeah
thank you so much gabrielle
our next question and i want to thank
again our audience members for these
great questions coming in we are having
a supply issue with our current
extraction kit provider can you confirm
that you have a full supply of chain
control of this kit
well yes actually i can take that one
again uh uh so yes so uh since you know
as i was mentioned at the beginning of
the presentation uh you know we uh kind
of normally are provided of components
for these type of kits
we manage the full supply chain we have
control of the whole supply chain
and i have to say we have a a lot of
capacity for for producing tests on this
console so we have a very good kind of
uh
supply for for our customers from this
one
thank you so much
our next question
would it be possible for us to have the
kit in bulk volumes outside your
standard 96 reaction kit for example
yeah well uh yes so actually we have uh
the the 96 but also we have a one 1000
reaction kit
which also allow us as we mentioned
before to address like really high
demands of uh you know up to millions of
reactions yeah so so yes so we can do a
1000 reactions and as i was saying
before because of the nature of how we
deal with our customers
we can even do other customized versions
as well but uh we can do bulk that's
what the answer is yes
thank you so much
now gentlemen what type of magnetic bead
is used in this kit
yeah so um
as mentioned what we have is a
magnetite super paramagnetic bead
so it that allows us for the
the protocol to run in a very convenient
manner so the the beats only come to the
magnet when the magnet is applied and
then can go back into solution very
readily afterwards
but
the surface chemistry is a silica based
chemistry
and people will be familiar with that
for nucleic acid extraction
uh on a number of different
methodologies historically
we've been able to apply the same
surface chemistry to these magnetic
particles and therefore it gives us a
familiar type of
production but in a very convenient
format using the magnetic
so the beads that actually we have used
in these kits which have all the
characteristics that chris has said are
our seracele maybe
so uh and uh as we want you know to to
kind of contribute as much as we as we
can is our way of of
of working with our customers we're also
willing to know to do and we are
commercializing those bits on their own
uh so if you want to to do your own kits
we're more than happy to help you with
that
thank you so much and we have a similar
question around the magnetic beads
our audience member wants to know for
rtpcr covid test which is the effective
way of isolation is it magnetic
bead-based or is it glass fiber spin
columns
yeah so
effectively both methods can be used um
the
keogen kit that was mentioned in the
data is a column based kit
and hopefully what you've seen in the
data is that the magnetic based kit that
we've provided gives equivalent
sensitivity and capability in terms of
that extraction
what we believe though is that the
magnetic beads offer more flexibility
when it comes to the numbers of samples
uh that the operator has for testing
they can be done manually in small
numbers with
little manual magnetic racks so you can
do anywhere up to a dozen tubes in a in
a single rack for example
but also it means that it can be
translated onto automation platforms
where you have 96 or even 384 well
handlers
with magnetic plates on the deck and so
that convenience in terms of being able
to go from small numbers right up to
very high throughput numbers
we believe offers equivalent performance
from the extraction point of view but
much greater flexibility from the user
perspective
thank you so much
now which automation platform is the kit
compatible with
so in theory it should be compatible
with with any
automation system that has a magnetic
separation capability
in terms of the data that we presented
we've been using the
kingfisher duo system
which is a small benchtop unit um allows
up to 96 well um handling of
of the testing um but we know we've
worked with customers that have also
used uh the really high throughput fully
automated liquid handling units like a
hamilton
system for example
but other
similar capabilities are provided by
many many automation
suppliers and as i say as long as they
have
the magnetic
capability to do that magnetic
separation should be compatible with
with any type of automation platform
thank you so much now how should sarah
extract a virus pathogen kit be stored
yeah so the kit is provided with a
number of components that are all proven
stability at room temperature
so
on arrival the kit can be stored at room
temperature
there is one component in the kit which
is the protein sk um once it's
reconstituted we suggest storing that at
colder temperatures um but it but that's
once you've opened the package as it
were and started using the kit
then that component perhaps needs uh
storing separately
but otherwise it's a room temperature
stable kit
thank you so much chris
we have time for a few more questions
and again i want to thank our audience
for this great um q a live discussion
could 903 cards be used for sample
collection in collaboration with the rna
dna extraction kit
absolutely yes that's
a great question and interestingly
something that we did look at uh very
briefly and and we have published some
information on this onto the website as
well
um so yes we used um some 903 cards
spiked with the similar samples to the
ones that i described in the in the talk
and we were able to get effective
extraction of the rna from those cards
so in theory yes that that's a feasible
route to take for uh sample collection
thank you so much and similarly another
question around extraction the
extraction is performed with a cocktail
of beads can you expand on that and is
the ratio kept the same for both the rna
and dna extraction protocols
and different starting material
uh yes at the moment that the
recipe and the protocol that we're
suggesting is the same for all of the
the um
sample targets that we've tested so far
um our plan moving forward is to try and
expand that range of targets uh that we
can demonstrate effect efficacy with
with the kit
um i think if we do find that anything
changes in respect to that cocktail then
we'll make sure to publish that data but
so far what we've seen is that that
cocktail and the recipe works
consistently for
a number of different pathogen targets
that we've been able to measure so far
yes
wonderful thank you so much
now how are you helping kit developers
like jenna drive with manufacturing can
you meet the capacity requirements
yeah i can take that one so uh yeah so
with g drive we are not
working on the uh extraction side
they're developing the rtpcr type of
things and what we do with them is what
is the life stable technology
which is uh establishing their reagents
so that normally those kids need to be
stored at a minus 30 degrees or
something or even a colder and with our
technology we are able to stabilize that
those regions so they are extraordinary
room temperature yeah and uh and so
that's the type of work we have been
doing with with gene drive and other
manufacturers around the around the
globe
on the of the reagents perspective
and uh yes so the capacity for that i i
think there's other sessions otherwise
for that but the categories the capacity
is really really big
yeah we're talking about millions yeah
um now uh with other kid developers uh
you know we're supplying uh beats and we
are supplying as well the the kit on the
on itself and and you know i think there
was some some mention that that we have
we were estimating that uh
i think until a couple months ago we
already helped to enable more than 50
million uh pcr tests around the world
yeah which is i i think that does give
you a sense of what is the capacity kind
of uh
that we we may address into the into
this problem
thank you so much looks like we have a
couple more questions here do you sell
the synthetic rna as a positive control
uh we don't at this time no we we
acquired that positive control from from
someone else for our testing
and we don't have that in our our
product range um if that if that was of
interest um
it would be good to know what sort of
amounts and what sort of use the the
customer would feel that that would be
beneficial for in their hands uh to run
alongside the the testing process uh so
maybe if there's uh
further information required or further
discussion required um perhaps there's a
way of connecting up in the um in the
conference hall around that one
wonderful perfect
now how effective is rapid antigen um
testing in comparison to rtpcr for covid
do you want to take that one gabriel
that was in your introduction
yes sure yeah and you know you know more
the think outside so so from my uh how i
how i'm looking to it so as i was
mentioned at the beginning of the of
this talk uh you know the
doing a test with through uh trying to
identify the antigen because of the
complexity of the
of it
it takes longer and it is more difficult
to really have that level of kind of
a reliability
while with a pcr test because you just
read the the sequencing of the rna
then you can get it faster but then you
have other constraints that i was
mentioned before yeah um
so i think right now there's a bit of a
race no uh and i think it's very
interesting because you can see you know
the a lot of companies working on a
rapid antigen kit and we we're
collaborating with some of them to help
them to to to to do that from the
scientific side uh
and then on the other side you have
a lot of ways that the pcr
related kind of assays have been
improved in terms of time in depth of
course in terms of simplicity and so
it is uh i don't think this
right now probably the gold standard it
remains the pcr
i we don't know what will happen next
six months uh that may change or that
may not uh
i don't know chris what are your take
yeah
yeah no i agree i think the other
important characteristic of the pcr test
is because of the application
amplification process the sensitivity is
is extremely high with the with the pcr
based tests um i must admit i'm not i'm
not up to date with exactly how far the
antigen tests have progressed and
certainly as gabrielle mentioned you
know that there's undoubtedly going to
be
in the future very effective
anti-antigen testing capabilities uh
available as well i think at the moment
as as he mentioned in terms of that gold
standard and particularly in terms of
sensitivity i think pcr is is probably
still the the preferred route
right
gentlemen thank you so much for your
presentation today it's been fabulous
i want to offer you an opportunity to
maybe provide some closing remarks um
gabrielle would you like to say anything
to the audience before we go today
sure uh so you know we are here at city
and not to help as much as we can with
this pandemic and we are happy to do
whatever way you know we can help with
the the extraction kids that we're doing
we were happy to provide the customized
we're happy to provide the beads we're
happy to pro to help with other reagents
we are happy to to help with other side
of the of this kind of a diagnostic
event so yes reach out to us uh because
you know that's our way of working is
really collaboratively with uh to just
to bring solution into this pandemic and
and yeah that's my
my thoughts
and chris yeah i think i'd i'd just like
to re reiterate that collaborative piece
i mean it's a
it's a strange time for everyone at the
moment and
i think we've been very keen to work as
closely as possible with customers to
understand their need not just so that
we you know we have a good product on
the market but to help with the
situation that is facing us all at the
moment and ensure that we have the best
possible reagents available to ensure
that testing is successful uh which i
think is is as we mentioned at the start
is critical uh to help um you know
resolve some of the the the things that
are happening right now
um so yeah if people have questions or
or need more help or more information
we're more than happy to to help
thank you both again for your
presentation
and i also want to thank our audience
members for their interesting questions
and their participation today and remind
you that any questions that were not
able to be answered today
will be answered via email and this
presentation will be available for
on-demand viewing for 12 months so
please remember to share it with your
colleagues who may have been interested
in the topic and missed today and do not
miss the other presentations on our
agenda visit the agenda tab in the
auditorium for a full listing thank you
again for your participation thank you
gentlemen until next time
stay safe
stay healthy
bye-bye
thank you thank you bye
you